this is all waris ali
has left photos of his wife
his son and his best friend
on what was most in part the perfect
holiday
but as they returned from the isle of
skye to their home in glasgow
a short stop at one of britain's largest
lakes ended
in utter devastation the kids standing
on pier
on the corner
he just tried to put fit inside the
water
but he suddenly dip water was deep
i think too deep and his
drawing and drawing in water and we all
run mean jump in water
awesome and when we drown in water
and my wife seen and she jumped i think
as well
the struggle at the northern end of loch
lomond in deep cold waters
meant nine-year-old harris his mother
adina and family friend asim
were victim to this horrific incident
juarez who spoke to us from his house
said without his family it no more feels
like a home
it was a weekend of tragedy across
scotland the rare sunshine has made
these waters more tempting than ever
but they can be dangerous and deceiving
even confident swimmers can experience
what's called cold water shock
where if you were to dive straight in or
you would be
submerged in you suddenly you're going
to very cold temperatures and your body
sort of shocks and you can get kind of a
gasp reflex as well
and which can mean people will really
struggle
in total six people died this weekend
from drowning
the first minister was left heartbroken
but these tragedies over the weekend are
a really brutal reminder that the beauty
of some of our waters often belies the
dangers
that they hold mr ali wanted to share
his story
so people could see the pain and the
loss that can be caused
properly
rashid sky news loch lomond